is that a hotel sheet is that a t-shirt
no one knows t-shirt that's hmm
debatable says the rest of society
hey guys grace Helbig here if you didn't
know now you know you cheap idiot just
kidding
you have redeeming quality tomorrow I am
headed to San Diego comic-con which is
comic-con in San Diego and in a couple
weeks I'll be going to VidCon in Anaheim
it is the season of the cons or
convention if you were unsure as to
whether I was talking about prison
inmates there always season I've been to
a lot of conventions in the past few
years so I've developed some personal
rules that have helped me handle
conventions more effectively so here are
my Ten Commandments yes this is a video
that I thought of the title for first
thou shalt have no other squads but the
commit to your nerd herd there is
strength in numbers get a group together
and stay with that group or at least
factions of that group conventions can
very quickly turn in to The Hunger Game
and not just because the Hunger Games
have a booth there but because it gets
very savage you need alliances now that
doesn't mean fight with other groups
work together rue the day my squad is me
and the map of all of the most private
bathrooms thou shalt not take graven
images with their idols you're going to
conventions I presume because you want
to meet certain people you want to take
photos or certain people but you need to
really think it through there's only so
little time to be had with every person
that you meet so really commit to
exactly what you want to do don't be
wishy-washy
cuz you're gonna end up with a sloppy
sloppy photo when you really want
something chic and sleek I'm a narc
trying to be a teenager know what kind
of photos you want be prepared to take
them had your phone out your camera out
have your buddy that's gonna take the
photos ready just make sure that you are
setting yourself up for success set
yourself up for success not suckiness my
lactose sensitivity might not allow me
to eat cheese but I can speak cheese all
damn day
inside note if you're waiting in long
lines which is the
at a convention and you're bored why not
listen to an audiobook I'm just like
what you hope that Convention Center is
full of plugs you know where this is
going already you are a very smart
person and that is why I enjoy you and
your patient audible.com supports a lot
of us youtubers so we support them by
telling you to go to audible.com slash
grace you can get a free trial and why
not listen to the audiobook of one of
the potential youtubers you could be
meeting at one of these said conventions
for instance I hate my selfie Shane
Dawson's book which is also narrated by
him on audible.com which i think is the
more fun way to consume all the stories
that he has to tell because you get to
hear him actually tell it and it's
fantastic so highly recommend and if you
go to audible.com such grace again you
can get a free trial so check it out
thou shalt not take the floor plan in
vain have a plan have some general idea
of where things are at the convention
what time things are happening and how
you can get to the most amount of things
you want to get to in the easiest most
efficient way possible there's a lot of
salmon swimming upstream at conventions
so make sure you're the salmon on the
jetski get right up there remember to
keep holy the Sabbath have a rest day or
a rest period at some point during the
day give yourself a chance to recharge
physically and technologically honor thy
mother and they father I know that you
refer to all of your idols as moms and
dads when you want to meet them at
conventions just be respectful
everyone's a human being turns out even
if they're dressed like robots and
non-human things there's a human being a
sweating under all of that makeup and
leather so let's treat everyone with
respect huh thou shalt not kill
on both a physical and nasal level no
murdering at conventions that's never
good also eat it up to all of us to
maintain our own
levels of Hygiene just like a campsite
it's up to all of us to maintain a clean
area and when we are all in such an
enclosed space together let's all be
responsible for that
let's uphold the sanctity of sent to T
titties there'll be a lot of titties
probably respect those too
thou shalt not commit adultery I'm not
talking about adultery I'm talking about
adult turi remember to be a kid
sometimes at these conventions this is a
place where you are supposed to
experience that cute list limitless
childlike unaffected joy so let yourself
do that no one is too cool at these
conventions
no one is cooler than anyone else it
just doesn't happen that way I'm sorry
even if your cosplay is cool dude 9000
no sorry
you are not cooler than iron crotch nope
thou shalt not steal don't steal there's
plenty of free swag also sub commandment
thou shalt not heal that's for me don't
wear high heels grace I know you're
going to so bring flats because there's
a lot of walking and a lot of standing
and those of you that are considering
wearing heels if it's not part of your
cosplay costume I would create some sort
of plan B for when your feet feel like
sheet can't stop won't stop should stop
but camp thou shalt not bear false
battery bring a Chargers thou shalt not
covet thy neighbor's goods or foods food
can sometimes be a minimum at these
conventions so make sure you create some
sort of plan for getting yourself
nourished because you could end up in
really long lines and fainting is not
trendy no I know those goats tried to
bring it back but you know keep yourself
replenished
also I like to make sure that I have a
convention emergency bag which has just
the bare essentials that I would need at
any moment throughout a convention in
there I could keep chargers hydration of
areas sorts resources financially you
gotta be able to pay for things either
have cash or credit cards on you and ID
sanitizer is always great because germs
are truly the real face of evil at these
conventions and Technology all check
stuff I need the phone charger phone
camera etc for tampons even if you don't
need tampons someone else might need
tampons and at a convention like this
tampons become very important currency
that's the one part that they didn't
really cover in the Hunger Games but you
better bet that Lenny Kravitz designed
something for that in that Mockingjay
outfit there you go there are my 10
commandments I hope that these are
helpful for you if you're going changing
the conventions and if you are I'll see
you there call me out if it smell real
bad
I don't know and in the past few years
my landline is ringing but what is the
weirdest part of that that it's ringing
or that I have a landline no one has
that number wouldn't this be funny if
this is how screams started if she just
never picked up the phone please stop I
don't have an answering machine this
could happen for hours oh my god I'll
give you three more rings I'm gonna
think about doing something one two why
would you still be calling it clearly
don't want to talk to you if I picked up
the phone now you'll be concerned that
either I was hurt or kidnapped and it
took me a long time to get to the phone
obviously didn't want to change my mind
now I'm talking to you on the phone and
this is awkward for both of us this is a
personal attack I came here to have a
good time and I'm just feeling attacked
right now
please stop ghosts who knew when I got
the internet landline package because it
was cheaper this would happen
comcast new now text me that I filled
full of a lot of anxiety right now